all right
so what will likely be happening in more
of this content is these mukbang Style
videos because there's just so many uh
ways to directly Point as best as
possible to no thing
everything and it's a bit overwhelming
how many ways there are to point to
it and so instead of doing single
episodes on a single pointing like
wholeness or Freedom or
unknowing there will be uh compilation
episodes like you see here where we're
going to go we're going to go over a
bunch of different
pointings all in a single stream in a
single episode so we're going to call
these
mukbangs so so buckle in for for these
because these will probably be coming up
more often
also all right so let's go ahead and
begin with entity impossible so that's a
very direct pointing that the center
point the me
separation is impossible it's impossible
for there to be an entity because if
there's an entity then that's Duality if
there's a me if there's a center point
that means there's another and if
there's another that means it's two and
if it's two that means it's not one
obviously
so so when the entity is clearly seen to
be impossible by nothing then it's
clearly seen that there's only nothing
everything and it's not known it's
unknowing everything
non-local
everying entity impossible so it's
impossible to actually form a me it's
impossible to actually form a center
point it's impossible for something
that's impossible to happen to
happen now there can be the elusory
contracted experience of there being a
me and
separation and all of the downstream
effects of war and violence and hatred
and whatnot from
that a very strong knowing
Cloud but it's impossible for it to
actually be the reality so it's just an
appearance it's just an ucer
apparent
happening it's not actually the case
actually the case is that there's it's
an impossibility for entities to be the
case the reality is the impossibility
for entities to be the case now there
are apparent bodies and those apparent
bodies have certain conditioned
preferences so there are certain things
that that there is the body that likes
to do certain bodies like to be out in
nature more certain bodies like to eat
certain kinds of
foods but those aren't entities those
aren't separate
entities there's no one behind the eyes
of the
bodies there is no one behind the eyes
bodies so behind the eyes of all bodies
is nothing
non-local freedom and unconditional love
is
ning and so when an entity is impossible
it's obviously seen that there's only
ising and therefore all of
these
contracted illusory me other War
separation hatred all those things
crumble
and fall apart and what's left is just
dawing decentralizing basic needs
infrastructures love joy Freedom
Prosperity abundance music dance comedy
laughter play all of the innocent things
that children and animals have that are
lost in the dualistic world of a
contracted adult that's either seeking
or
lacking or believing in separation with
its strong knowing
Cloud so this is a very beautiful one
entity
impossible and then we have unachievable
nonseparation so what this is saying is
that non-separation is always the case
and therefore it's
unachievable so nonlocality or
nonseparation is always the case or non-
entity
is always the
case it's not something that can be
achieved
nonseparation non-
Entin a non-locality is not an
achievement because it's always the case
so it's always what's already
here that's why it's
unachievable you see so the contracted
experience of me which is wholeness or
no thingness appearing as that it wants
an achievement of attaining
non-separation it wants an achievement
of attaining Enlightenment or Awakening
but it's not possible because it's
literally what is which is already death
it's already non-locality it's already
unconditional love and freedom that is
in that seeking of
itself that's why it's unachievable it's
unattainable able it's another way to
say it unattainable non-separation it's
unattainable it's
unachievable it's never going to happen
it's hopeless it's never going to happen
because it's already
not there is already no
separation there is already only non
locality and non- entity everything
there is only unknowing no thinging
there is only that ning there's only
that there's already no entity there's
already no separation that's why it's
unachievable it's unattainable it's
never going to happen it's never going
to be earned it's never going to be
attained it's never going to be an
achievement
and that's why it's absolutely futile to
talk about a me that's on a
transformative Journey it's absolutely
futile to brag about accolades or
achievements or attainments on a
spiritual journey because there's
already no entity there's already no
separation it's literally Freedom or no
thing that is bragging about something
attainments that are not actually
happening
all right so now we'll go
into
the simple
vacancy another word that I had here was
extreme it's like an extreme vacancy but
it's also a very simple
vacancy so it's obviously not occupied
this is not occupied by an entity bodies
are not occupied by entities they're not
occupied by mes they're vacant bodies
are vacancies there's only vacancy in
all
bodies it's vacancy that is
ising and it's quite extreme in the
sense that
it's very simple and ordinary but it's
extreme in the sense of it does not give
any concession to their being a duality
it does not give any concession to their
not being a vacancy it does not give any
concession to their being the real
experience of a body being occupied by
an entity and that's what pisses the
[__] out of
me because it can't get a validation of
its dualistic
journey and therefore if there's a
ripeness if there's an openness if
there's the no thingness
that is truly in uh
unknowing it will that contracted
meanness that is trying to grasp and
detain it'll relax into the non- eness
that already
is so it is a simple vacancy the vacancy
is everywhere the vacancy is in all
babies all babies are vacant all
dying uh uh old AG bodies are
vacant and uh animals are
vacant they're absolutely vacant there's
no entity inside we just add a name or a
label and then we create the artificial
constructs of
Separation but there is no name or label
there is no entity
inside there's never been an entity
inside it's not possible for there to be
an entity inside it is always a simple
vacancy simply vacant simply vacant it's
another great way to say it simply
vacant simply empty simply whole already
free unconditional love ising it's
already that it's already non-local
there's already no distance no se
separation no time no space between what
appears to be the different bodies
there's already no difference no time no
space between the apparent differing
bodies they're all the
same they're all the same no thing
everything that's what this is and it's
absolutely unknowable it's absolutely
ineffable but it's so simple and
ordinary it's too simple and ordin orary
saying vacancy is so simple and ordinary
because it's literally what's happening
as everything
already so the animals are already
vacant the babies are already vacant old
bodies that are passing are already
vacant it's all already vacant there's
only that contracted experience of me
that is located inside of a body that is
separate and must attain that is the
only within boundlessness within this
unconditional love of non-entity there
that is the only place for there to be
an occupation the appearance the
experience of an apparent
occupation it's mind [__] and
mindblowing that that's even
possible in something that is obviously
non- Entin something that is obviously
vacant in something that is obviously
vacant and empty there can be the
appearance of an experience of an entity
that is occupying a body and that is
[__]
mind-blowing crazy and so another way to
say this is that there is no
you this is also very simple no you
there isn't a
you there isn't a
me there isn't a
we there isn't a
they there isn't an
i all of those things collapse because
they're not there there is only the
vacant non-entity
non-locality wholeness there is only
that there's only
that and it can freely appear as a
contracted sense of separate meaning
it can freely appear as a as a
u
uh I am real I am name I am located in
body I am seeking I must attain I am
unho I am unworthy I need to earn
[Music]
validation it's
so suffering so
suffering that whole function of meing
is suffering and it's already not
happening there is already no me there
is already know you there is only that
non-entity
non-locality that is there's only
wholeness that
is and it's obvious when that's seen by
nothing that the me was a complete
illusion in fabrication and totally
unreal total dream that then all of this
dawing is home Dow this decentralized
autonomous organizations around the
prosperity and abundance and freedom of
basic needs Joy play all of these
incredible things that innocent children
love it's proliferated across all of the
the apparent
earthscape so everything that is sought
cannot be attained by me because it
already is in its empty wholeness and
from from that empty wholeness from that
clear no thinging Dow is perfectly
harmonious so let's
see boundless and boxless this one is Al
also
obvious
so yes just
replying
in the live chat thanks for tuning in
totally it's unconditional love speaking
of unconditional love as unconditional
love within unconditional love
absolutely everything that is said
everything that is heard is all
unconditional love yes it's all no thing
it's all that already it's all that
already there's nowhere to go from that
there's nowhere to go from what's
already no thing everything there's
nowhere to go from unconditional love
being these words that are said that are
heard that's it that's it there's
nowhere to go from that that's
it but it's the end of the illusion of
the separate individual it's the end of
the illusion of a lacking me in a world
of separate others
and and me is convinced that it w can't
give that up because it can find
fulfillment it can find wholeness it can
attain a permanent happiness and
satisfaction through
objects through experiences through
whatever modalities of of seeking and
attaining but it's absolutely futile and
impossible and
so that's the hilarity of of the cosmic
joke it's literally wholeness and
fulfillment that is experiencing an
elusory contraction that is seeking
wholeness and
fulfillment
we yeah love
it okay so we'll continue on this so
boundless and boxless
the fullness another comment the
fullness of emptiness is there if I am
not yes
exactly it's all already empty and full
and whole and beautiful and perfect but
when I am real separate solid hard
seeking
dissatisfied then all of the empty whole
fulfillment Perfection beauty is all
gone it's all absolutely
gone it's so contracted and truly
suffering all right boundless and
boxless so this one is obvious also it's
the inability to bound it's the
inability to
box there's no there's this is no thing
everything it's not possible to bound or
box
it no thing everything means not boxing
not bounding boxless
boundless and that wholeness appearing
as that contracted experience of me of I
am real I am here and I
know that is all the time boxing and
bounding that that lives in boxing and
bounding everything is a box or a bound
everything is about meaning everything
is about how does this water bottle how
does this relate to my Center Point why
is it so
meaningful all of these experiences that
are happening to me to this Center Point
are so meaningful and each experience is
a box each experience is an object it's
its own B
and the bounds are my story my life I am
real I am solid I am seeking I am unho I
will tell you my endless stories and
journey of transformation box box box
bound bound bound listen to me validate
me I want to be worthy I am
unworthy and so that Loops in a small
tiny stinky Little Pond of selfing of me
in that is all made of Unknowing it's
made of already wholeness of already no
thingness and so this boundless this
boxless is already the case and so it's
a ceasing of that obsession with boxing
and bounding that is like a refrigerator
hum of boxing and
[Music]
bounding
and that refrigerator home of boxing and
bounding is gone and there's only
boundless boxless obvious empty
wholeness spontaneity there's only
that
yeah and there's no
registar also
another very clean direct pointing
there's no registar because there's no
me there's no U there's no Center Point
and therefore there's no shelf there's
no filing system right so that the
illusion of there being someone inside
that is grabbing boxes or files or
bounds or concepts or ideas grabbing
them making a big story of meaning out
of them and then storing them in some
sort of Mirage like file system is a
complete
illusion and this is great there's a a
comment in the chat about DMT much this
is the classic thing and it's been
talked about on so many of these
episodes and streams is that this is
actually the natural spontaneous empty
wholeness this is natural and in the
appearance of the natural is the
illusion of the unnatural and the
unnatural is really the Psychedelic
experience of a Center Point point it's
the Psychedelic experience of a me
everything that's being described here
is the not to so it's the it's because
it's it's it's ineffable and so what is
done is described what it's not and what
it's not is that ucer contracted Center
Point and that ucer contracted Center
Point is absolutely the trippiest most
psychedelic thing imaginable something
that is boundless empty whole free
unconditional love without entity or
location somehow
psychedelically assumes entity location
time space name form
objects lack
meaning something that is boundlessly
free without any of those things assumes
and contracts into the hilarity of those
things
so yeah there are and in the comments
there's comments about advancements in
in
physics yeah there's lots of
advancements in physics that are uh that
are onto the no thingness yes but it's
unknowable so it's not going to be known
by an entity it's just a pointing to no
thing everything and it doesn't matter
if that's it's always already the case
and it doesn't matter if
it's if
it's uh if it's looked at through a lens
of of physics or if it's looked at by no
one through a lens of of simple ordinary
spontaneous Infinity it just doesn't um
doesn't matter absolutely doesn't
matter and this is always great cuz
there's always sort of the asking oh
like but how did the me unwind how did
it unwind and there's no answer to that
because a it was never there and B it
can unwind in Endless apparent ways
anything from just simply walking
outside being in nature driving a car
eating a
burger meditating
psychedelics books looking at um eyes
it's like just there's just too many uh
way it's non-causal is another way to
say it it's non-causal the unwinding of
me is a
non-causal because it's non-existent the
me already isn't therefore its unwinding
is
non-causal
me is already non-existent therefore its
unwinding is
non-causal how does something that isn't
have a cause of how it
stops it's not
possible a comment about uh Bernardo
castra we've had Bernardo on the
show so it's it's just this is this is
the thing this is the thing there will
be endless pointings to oh have have
which physics or which spiritual
teachers or which Consciousness
researchers or gurus or books or
psychedelics or whatever and all of that
is
simply the
continuation of saying that this isn't
it and what is being shared here is that
this is it
and even those pointings to teachers or
researchers or gurus or books or
psychedelics or Retreats or whatever
that's all it too so there's no escaping
it there's no moving closer to or
further from it it's already here it's
simply this it's already only this it's
just too ordinary the non-local empty
wholeness that this is is just too
ordinary and so it's always uh but I'll
but I'll get it in the next studying of
the next knowledge of the next knowing
of the next concepts of the next
experience and it will never ever happen
because it already is the case so it's
not possible to happen because it's
already the unconditional Freedom
itself I'm not sure I've uh checked out
the being in
nothingness in the
comments um
yeah so this is this is really this is
really it this is really it there's
nowhere to go from
this there's no way to um suggest that
there is an experience or that there is
a book or that there is a way or a path
to get or attain or read about or learn
about is already there's no way to read
or learn or know what this is that's why
it is the unknowing it is the unknowing
the UN locality the UNC
contracti the wholeness The
Emptiness the no
thingness and this registar is a
complete illusion there's no entity
inside there's no controller or doer
inside that is grabbing meaning in its
bounds and boxes and ideas and Concepts
and sorting them and organizing them
into a story of my
life that is
not it's a complete illusion that is
not and that's the thing is that there's
nowhere to go from that if there's no
registar then this is all no thing ever
everything this is all always already
that and
there's there's no way to grab
onto
anything there's obviously no registar
obviously and that registar is
equivalent to me it's equivalent to a
center point it's equivalent to that
contraction in the body that wants to
control and manipulate the appearance to
fulfill its sense of lack for its its
desire for freedom and wholeness which
is already the
case uh what do you think about Dua in
the comments
so here's the thing man suffering is SE
suffering is meing suffering is selfing
it's just too simple this is already
wholeness it's already no thing
everything and suffering is simply that
appearance within wholeness that says I
am real I am solid I am name I lack I am
separate and I must seek wholeness
fulfillment
Freedom that that's that's what it
that's it's just too simple it's too
simple it doesn't require all these
elaborations and Retreats and books and
conceptual studies it it those things
may appear to happen um and there's no
value system if it's better to not study
dooka or if it's better to study dooka
you know that doesn't exist anymore
there's no value system there's no
pathway but the illusion is that by
conceptually studying what Dua or
suffering or emptiness or unknowing or
any of these things by studying it I
will attain it is a complete illusion
because it's already the case it's
already
emptiness trying to learn about what
trying to learn a concept or some sort
of knowing that will then inform uh it
about what it is which is not possible
because it's already the case it can't
learn about itself through ad through
addition
yes just total love total wow it's
really simple and easy and that's why
these these last things are about uh
completeness and a fresh new
so everything everything is fresh
everything is new everything is complete
everything is wow like in the live chat
everything is that it's always already
forever that and it's never been not
that one second just going to tell the
community I'm recording one second
because I can hear their
voices
just good yeah I
got thank
you
okay all right just we let him know
don't we got here so no way all seeking
a selfish and illusion yeah
absolutely
yep it's just too obvious that it's
already and so any trying to grab it or
attain it or earn it is elusory
yes and um yeah the completeness of it
is also absolutely beautiful
and uh that actually speaks perfectly to
the completeness of it
also because it's already complete it's
just too obvious how complete it
is and it's not an attainment to earn
completeness it's that the completeness
already
is and so it's naturally
spontaneously complete the empty
Luminosity is always already complete
it's never an attainment and nor is it
ever
obstructed it's never actually
obstructed and so it's just complete
it's fresh it's new it's wow it's ising
ising ising ising ising ising and that's
why that's why it's
nonu because when it's izing there's
nowhere to go there's no nowhere to say
oh okay so then um there there is uh uh
there's no difference between it being
wholeness and it being the appearance of
a contraction in the body that is
lacking and seeking there's no
difference between those two things
those two things are actually one thing
and so therefore there is just that
ising
ising the abortion or uh pointings of
wholeness only or
unknowing those are just responses to
the me that is believing in Duality and
then manipulating or controlling the
appearance and so then the body just
naturally responds and just cuts that
Duality by saying that there's only
wholeness there is already no
entity The Entity is already impossible
there is already already no you there is
already no
registar non-separation is already
unachievable you're there's already a
vacancy there there's already only a
vacancy
everywhere and yes great comment there
in the live chat the dream of separation
is izing appearing as that so there's no
there's no way to create a duality it's
impossible to create a duality ising is
always already and ising is appearing as
a dream of I'm separate I'm real I'm
solid I lack I need Etc there's no
Duality it's so perfect beautiful
Indescribable just like the most
beautiful imaginable is this
already I'm excited to make more of
these U mukbangs
because it's a good way to to uh offload
uh an a a larger amount of the ways to
point to no thing everything and also it
creates some fun spontaneity and
bounciness between the um
pointings and it continues to just cut
and undermine the illusion of there
actually being a you of there actually
being an entity of there actually being
a registar of there actually being the
possibility of achieving non-separation
there's no way to achieve the freedom
and unconditional love and wholeness and
unknowing there's no way to achieve it
because it is already it is already
there is already no entities anywhere so
it is impossible to
achieve there's already no separation
anywhere it is impossible to
achieve empty ESS is already everywhere
it is impossible to
achieve and so there is some sort of a a
Readiness in that contracted sense of me
which is which can hear which is this
nothing that is
hearing and it's and it's uh it's what
that contracted sense of me is made of
and that that that unknowing when it
when it hears that there's no
entity
there can be uh a really a relieving or
an unwinding of that contracted delusion
into the non-locality and unconditional
love that everything already was and
then that the body the body's function
which was oh my God I lack I
need that function is ceased and then
the function of the body is natural
dawing it's basic needs abundance
play see that's how that that
functionality can shift and
change and it's all made of the same
ising and it's just ising appearing as
that ucer
contraction and it's just so beautiful
when the that elusory
contraction is uh that that no thing
clearly sees that that ucer contraction
is a complete joke and the entity is not
whoa look at these fireworks holy [__]
that was the first time I saw that
animation that was [__] cool
whoa I wonder if this is happening in uh
OBS I need to look up if uh the what the
OBS animations are cuz these things are
great there's been like balloons and uh
confetti and a thumbs up and all kinds
of fun
stuff um yeah so there's a there's a
question in the chat about how often do
you meditate and did you meditate on the
journey so again I'm I'll this will just
reply and say that there's no causality
there's no causality that
gets non-locality to be the reality
non-locality unconditional love and
freedom is already this it's already it
so it's not uh going to be uh elaborated
on as a story of causality of oh yeah
this body went on cuz it did it did go
on apparent 10day long silent meditation
Retreats and it did apparently take
psychedelics and it did apparently read
lots of books and sit with lots of
teachers and that's all just a story
it's just a story because it's already
here now this obviously
unobscured it's already no thing
everything oh yeah
Jason res a georan that was a good that
was a good
interview yeah we'll
see perhaps uh these uh some of these
peeps that we've interviewed perhaps
they'll come through Austin and if so
would love to sit down with them in
person we already have some guests
scheduled for next week which is very
exciting woo let's go um and uh yeah I
guess we'll see how
um how all of this continues morphing
there's obviously lots of
streams
um and then there's interviews and then
there's these mukbangs that have more
uh like combo of stuff it's fascinating
actually
um yeah that last one on separation porn
was fascinating too
um a question would you interview Elon
Musk absolutely yeah I just uh messaged
I did Outreach to the um SpaceX and
Tesla offices uh just yesterday asking
to interview Elon so absolutely I would
and uh same thing for Joe Rogan I just
messaged yesterday and plenty of other
uh Comedians and all stars and stuff
around around the area
Lex fredman messaged him to and it would
be fun it'd be really fun to sit down
with it feels most ripe and most ready
now than ever to
uh to have the conversations with um
with them about this
so and it's really fascinating because a
lot of them are interested in
Consciousness but
not as Consciousness being no
everything not not Consciousness as a
non-local
Unity as a non-local no one
everyone and that's that's sort of where
the where the current um in in what
what's appearing to what's seeming to
happen is that there's some sort of a of
a of a in a way a resistance to
um mind or Consciousness or awareness
which are just conceptual additions to
the body but there's sort of a of of a
resistance to those ideas being no thing
everything which is which is of course
that's um that's also what was happening
with this body too is that there was a
resist existence to no thing everything
because there was really a a strong um
sense of me and Center Point in locality
and lack and the last thing that that
wants is its absence but the reality is
it's already absent there's already no
Center Point there's already no me
there's already only a vacancy there's
already only an
absence this is just too easy
man it's just a simple vacancy
it is a simple
vacancy yes would also uh interview uh
RFK Jr
yep yeah um yeah the not to or
non-duality is in a way can appear to be
antithetical to politics definitely
because and that's what was discussed in
the last episode on on separation porn
is that um politics is all about
separation porn it's all about me it's
all about my nation state State it's
about my people it's about my religion
it's about my ethnicity it's about my
military industrial complex it's about
manipulating using social media and
extremism to uh create hatred towards
others and it's just separation porn
separation porn is uh what's is
wholeness separation porning that's
emptiness separation
porning that's
one way to describe the
appearance the intensity of the apparent
geopolitical Madness and separation porn
is all unconditional love separation
porning and it actually in a way it's
makes perfect sense although it's
complete unknowing but it makes perfect
sense in a way that unconditional
Freedom would arise as this insane
apparent separation porn
yeah it's complete Simplicity yes the
live chat it's just complete
Simplicity that's why another thing that
this body has been doing it's just
like
meow
because that's just utter Simplicity you
can't a Seeker can't get something from
woof
woof meow they just can't get anything
from
that because it's too simple empty and
ordinary and the Seeker can't extract
any meaning from
it yeah a Seeker is neurotic
is just bouncing to more
experience all right
so what do we got here we got this first
mukbang which was super fun loved it we
have a entity
impossible yeah such fun pointings
entity impossible unachievable
non-separation a thanks for that that
comment yeah Frank yeah love him so much
yeah we'll likely we'll have uh we'll
have Frank back on and we'll likely do
some more content with him
soon
um yeah there's another comment about
about like Freud and you and about these
uh there's been this body has apparently
studied the core of psychology and
psychoanalysis and Etc and what's seen
uh by no one is that all of that is just
conceptual elaboration and conceptual
fabrication and conceptual masturbation
and
ideological conceptual knowing and it's
just absolutely exhausted by
nothing yeah all of those narratives
belong to
me me lives in The Narrative of
psychology psychoanalysis Neuroscience
therapy experience
seeking expansions trauma
healing
Etc and it's all made of nothing and so
obviously as it's seen by nothing that
all of that is an absolute conceptual
masturbation
but that's very uncomfortable to me me
thrives on its conceptual knowing so for
nothing to reflect back to me and say
that all of these greatest Minds that is
being clung to is a complete conceptual
masturbation is very
annoyed CU it's always been non- eness
there is no
Freud there is no Musk
there is no you there is no anyone
there's only non- Entin bodying there's
only
wholeness it's so it's too simple it's
too ordinary and there's me is too
attached to names and a story over
time but it's just too simple and
ordinary there's never been
entities there's only been wh
bodying so non-separation is literally
unachieved achievable it's unattainable
because it's already the
case I love that one so
much no thingness is unattainable
because it's already the case unknowing
is already the case non-locality is
already the case it's
absolutely
unattainable so all efforts to attain or
to know or to achieve Freedom or
wholeness are absolutely futile
absolutely
futile and again it's a simple simple
vacancy it's way too
simple there's already no one
home it's a simple vacancy there's no
one home there's no
you it's just emptiness hessing
emptiness ising it's only that there's
already no one home there's no
transformative Journey that a separate
me can go on to achieve non-separation
and wholeness and
freedom it's really this boundless
boxless inability to contract inability
to box or bound or conceptually
masturbate and
elaborate we get a little zoom out to
the
nips it's been fun playing with the nips
on the show nipple action yeah yeah
nipple action yeah yeah nips nips nips
nips nips nips nips nips nips nips nips
nips nips nips nips nips nip nipple
nipple nip nip nipple nipple nip nip
nipple nipple nips
yeah and you see me or that contracted
apparent energy in the
body it isn't free it doesn't feel free
it feels like there's shame like there's
an inability to to talk about genitals
or to show genitals or to uh rub nipples
or to
um or wanting to hide wanting to hide
certain um information so there's just
an absolute free flowing from no
everything that is completely free
there's no straight jacketing anything
genitals anything sex anything uh about
the story anything that it has no no
defenses it's just totally free flowed
no
perfected so
good
there's a comment about a dog being Guru
yeah yeah the yeah the unconditional
love of the dog the non- eness of the
dog the non- eness of the cat and the
unconditional love and purring that is
obviously what is it's just so obvious
there's no entity it's just pureness
just innocence it's unconditional
love and then there's another comment
about children being closer to uh the
realization so again just to be clear
this isn't a realization it's not
something that's realized by someone
realization in a way is another way to
say seeking it's another way to say that
this is not
already no thing everything realization
is about later realization is about
something that could happen if I'm a
very good boy or a good girl that
studies a
lot it's not a
realization it's a no thing clearly
seeing that the me never was that it
never
happened that it was just an illusion it
was just a
dream it was just a
masturbation it's literally
wholeness seeing that that it was just
me
masturbation it's just a me
masturbation and yes children
um uh in in many ways um there's plenty
of of children that are not conditioned
with separation and uh locality and um
somethingness and so when a child is not
conditioned with somethingness then
obviously there is a non-local no
everything in and it's very apparent in
dogs and
cats woof woof
meow so yeah boundless boxless no
registar same thing as no you no
entity same thing as there is only a
vacancy complete
fresh new
ising
yeah fresh new
ising yum yum
[Music]
yum all
right well that was a fun that was a fun
first
mukbang
uh here in Austin and looking forward to
more
mukbangs it's just a fun format to
it
um and uh thanks for joining in the live
chat that was a lot of fun and probably
be on again later today we'll
see
and it's
just so
simple
home for No
One h
yeah you're welcome in the live chat and
thanks for uh watching
commenting
yeah
Dow this prosperous
joyful
playful basic needs met free
bodies love it oh
okay all
right
bye